y como ya lo decíamos hoy en directo a
hablamos del ciclón yaku que ha golpeado
fuertemente a Perú dejando al menos 58
muertos y su influencia también se
siente en Ecuador donde se han
registrado fuertes precipitaciones e
inundaciones justamente conectamos con
Gustavo Ortega corresponsal en Quito
para ampliar los detalles Gustavo Cuáles
son los estragos que deja ya tras su
paso por el país
Sí buenas noches principalmente los
estragos han sido en las provincias
costeras de este país específicamente la
provincia de guayas y en el cantón
chores que pertenece a la provincia de
manabí donde se han sentido los
principales estragos y deslizamiento de
tierra se habla ya de mil afectados y
hasta el momento se registran cinco
fallecidos por estas inundaciones El
Ejecutivo nacional ha dicho que han
caído por lo menos solo en la provincia
de guayas 18 millones de metros cúbicos
de agua y esto ha ocasionado diferentes
inundaciones deslizamientos cierre de
vías y afectaciones Y damnificados en
este país también se habla de colapso de
vías y sobre todo personas verificadas
que han sentido las consecuencias por
las intensas lluvias que se producen en
este país que coinciden con el invierno
en Ecuador que se producen desde
mediados de febrero el día de hoy el
instituto de meteorología ha dicho que
la noche de hoy hacerla más intensa
donde se caerán persistentes lluvias no
solo la capital ecuatoriana en la zona
interandina sino también en el litoral
ecuatoriano y en la región amazónica
Gustavo Cuál es la situación en este
momento de Los afectados y que ayudas ha
anunciado al gobierno para acompañarlos
para apoyarlos
pero básicamente la principal
consecuencia hasta el momento se
registra cinco personas fallecidas como
te he comentado también se comentan que
en principio se hablaba de 563 personas
damnificadas Pero ya el número de
personas ha Doblado inclusive esta cifra
que ha hecho El Ejecutivo nacional bueno
ha hablado de entrega de bonos de
desastres ha dicho que
ofrecerá principalmente ayudas
económicas y créditos también para la
reactivación económica se registra hasta
el momento por lo menos pérdidas de el
sector agropecuario mil productores
agropecuarios han perdido su cosechas
también se ha hablado sobre la
construcción de hospitales
en el específicamente en la ciudad de
chone Se ha perdido el hospital
principal de esta ciudad que tenía 40
años de construcción y tiene pérdidas y
recuperables El Ejecutivo nacional
hablado de la construcción de un nuevo
hospital y en la ciudad de Guayaquil hay
zonas donde se han colapsado por el agua
no se mantiene Se ha perdido el servicio
el servicio de agua potable y
básicamente se habla
de 54 casos de electospirosis la
principal preocupación sanitaria que en
este momento mantiene el país a causa de
estas intensas lluvias